and think about a public transit company
that is works on a margin of like five
percent six percent yes so
that's a big deal ten percent more five
percent more it's big big deal i think
that was like the main factor why we got
uh quite quite fast involved you see
like this away you can't really ignore
it
it doesn't really matter what tool you
use today you really want to move to
that because
you get like an immediate ally
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
let's talk about public mobility
meet amos hajjaj ceo and co-founder of
optibus a software platform that
nourishes freedom of movement and
sustainable cities by bringing much
needed innovation to public
transportation
before co-founding octobus in 2014
almost led the development of
large-scale personalization engines as a
senior software development engineer at
microsoft and designed machine learning
algorithms at siemens he is the
recipient of several prestigious math
and technology awards including the
intel prize for software engineering the
elkin prize for information technology
and the wolf prize for mathematics
[Music]
welcome to 20 minute leaders how are you
great thanks for having me
thank you so much for being here optibus
you know one of the companies we're most
proud of in in our tiny but beautiful
israel and and you know a company that
not only is doing something really cool
technologically but it's really changing
and shaping the way that people interact
with their surrounding and with the
world around the world so operating in
more than 500 cities probably that
linkedin post isn't updated either and
it's more than that by now and and and
where and you know just
trying to figure out wrapping my head
around public transportation and how a
company from israel is is working
globally and helping shape
transportation for for millions and
billions i think that's just
mind-boggling and so i'm very thankful
that you're here almost who are you how
you know how do you get to start a
company in public transportation that
operates around the world
yeah um
the story for october so we founded
opticals in 2014 but the story begins uh
years before
my background
is in tech i studied math and computer
science
back in 2004
during
first year at university i met eitan uh
who later become a co-founder of optibus
and he's the cto today of the company
i met him at university we're both
studying computer science and math we're
studying together
my father was the cfo of one of the
largest public transit companies in
israel so that's the connection right
and one day it was first year at
university so a long time ago it was
telling me about the problem of
planning transit systems planning of
network and how it's being done today oh
back then
uh
now just to make sure i understand this
when you say planning public transport
that means literally planning the routes
of the bus system and what streets
they're going to and where we're going
to put the stations right right it's uh
so planning of public transportation is
many different things it's planning the
routes is playing the network where the
route should go where should the
allocate stops what should be the
frequency
of the timetable in night morning
weekend so on but it's also a lot about
the resource allocation how many drivers
you need
vehicles could use a double decker
single decker bus
electric bus versus diesel uh should the
driver come at 7 00 am or 8 pm or you
know night shift morning shifts how many
drivers you need over time there's so
many operational questions
uh and what amazed them so you come from
the financial side public transit is
quite an expensive business to run
i think even small cities will spend
something around 100 million dollars a
year
of running public transit system and if
you look at the large cities let's take
london is about 17 billion
annual budget of running public transit
system new york is about the same wow
yeah yeah it's significant uh amount of
money goes into
vehicles drivers operations so so back
to the to the beginning of the story my
father was telling me that
it's all being done manually
seems to him like sub-optimal decision
made by people based on their experience
very experienced people by the way
throughout time we learned
what an amazing job they're doing
because they're doing all of that
manually based on you know their own
experience and and
intuition but think about people sitting
in a room
and they're saying hey let's stay let's
have a driver takes this route and then
we have this vehicle use that route and
we'll switch the drivers here and
everything is done manually
it's like
billions and billions and billions of
options it's like
uh
unimaginable to just uh
seeing a person doing that so he was
telling me about that i was first here
at university very complex problem we
can touch that in in a minute if you
want uh extremely complex mathematically
um we didn't have any clue of how to
even
approach so but at least we knew that
there is a problem and it exists
uh basically throughout time ayton and
me started thinking about the problem
so we completed our studies i then went
to the u.s to princeton i did
all research around medical imaging
completely different uh topic but uh
around the x-ray machine and trying to
detecting a coronary artery blockage and
things like that
and later on worked at microsoft in yet
another completely different uh topic of
uh cortana which was a personal
assistant
of microsoft uh building
what became cortana but basically trying
to match content uh to people needs and
and uh as a personal system
and during all that time we basically
started at the beginning thinking about
the problem and then we had some ideas
about how to solve it mathematically
the algorithms and so on we had really
initial tool that was based on files it
was getting a file it was running old
optimization and outputting you know
result
it was when i look at what we have today
it was nothing even compared to what we
have today but i think it's like the the
best definition of an mvp
minimal viable product uh it was really
bad
but like when i when i see what what it
did back then
but it gave better results than what
they had
what the ad was
was also bad
but what we have today is great what we
have there is that still
it still was much better because it was
much better we had public transit
agencies first in israel then later on
the u.s europe
just want to use
this
magic
called optibus of these two guys that
was working out of their basement
that can take the entire transit system
of a city and optimize it in under a
minute that was like kind of a magic for
everyone that does the work that used to
take months and months
and
in a minute you'll get to much better
results meaning millions of millions of
savings and all that
what are some factors that you know come
into mind when you're if i were to
design a
transportation system within a city
let's say i'm creating a new city what
are some things that i need to consider
you know for the for the layman who who
has no idea what this may entail right
so
as i said before transportation has
different parts uh the
the more strategic planning when when
you say have a new city
it's something like that right we have
cases by the way where it is like a new
city
so we do like event transportation you
have a large event it can be like
a large music festival
or a large sport event or something like
that
you have all the people
that come to that event and you want to
design the best transportation system
for these people
so it's they are kind of there is
nothing there right it's a new event
so basically when you look at strategic
planning you look at mostly demand and
budget
so where people live where they work
uh also transportation a lot about
equity
so
it's not only about you know what's
worse the biggest demand but who are the
people who needs transportation the most
low income population different type of
population that maybe don't have a car
uh maybe the only way of getting to work
is using a bus or you know public
transit so you want to make sure that
for these type of communities you
definitely have
a service
where they need and so so you take all
this all this into account you build a
network a network is a set of routes and
timetable
for different time of day in different
days of the week and so on and how those
routes interact with each other
uh so for example if you have one
corridor like one main
street in the city you have many routes
going through that corridor
so you want to look at the frequency of
all these routes together and uh if you
have a railing
and a bus route you want the bus to get
to the rail before the rail leave the
station so all this coordination that
would be the first part and that's what
we call planning
the second part is what we call
scheduling which is how many vehicles
you need how many drivers
type of vehicle you know one driver gets
to work all these things how much
they're getting paid uh over time uh
when they get the day off all of the
scheduling part
then the last part is actual operation
optimus is like an operating system for
public transit it does anything from
thinking about what you should uh design
to actually operate it right now right
what's happening right now what do you
do with this driver it's replaces that
driver a vehicle breakdown
i have you know all this so um
we have analytics platform
yeah so it's it's the full suite but
uh to your question like if you're
designing all city you start from what
should be the network but usually when
we go to let's say city like london or
uh you know los angeles and so on there
is an existing transit system and we
want to improve that
right exactly and and so i'm trying to
wrap my head around you know the site
this idea that you know you and a few
friends you know you're you're building
this fantastic
you know idea with a with a big pain
point with deep technology and all of a
sudden you're working with agencies and
with
with you know local authorities all
around the world you know what is that
experience like what does that mean for
you as an entrepreneur what are the
challenges that may come with that
yeah first i'm really i'm always really
excited about that like i i even today
like after seven years
like on the fact that you know a company
from israel
that definitely started small now it's
quite large but
it's actually responsible powering today
we're doing almost 50 of the entire
public transit network of the entire uk
including london and all of the uk right
uh almost everywhere i just been in
london last week
almost every bus you see is is paradigm
to bus
almost everything that happens there uh
routes in in yorkshire and different
parts of the uk in the us and singapore
and hong kong and brazil and
uh so even today is still amazed by by
the fact that you know such an impact in
so many places in the world uh it wasn't
easy it was really really hard and it's
still hard all the time even today or
octopus is really de facto standard
of of you know public transit uh systems
it's hard you need to work with uh
large transit agencies that use to use
the same kind of methods bitpin and
sales files or legacy system whatever
but they used to do the same thing for
like in the last
40 years right
and here's a company coming from you
know a new shiny tool and so on but why
should we change
so yeah we develop throughout time
methods of showing the value of our
system before someone needs to make a
decision to purchase so we can take all
the data
of let's say new york put it into
optibus
run all the algorithms and show them how
it can look like
before you start using the system and
it's actually quite accurate uh of what
you do on paper versus what you actually
get in the field
and what was the growth like for you was
it you know first finding you know
product market fade making sure that it
works for one two cities and then
opening up and and onboarding
498 more or was it more linear what was
that like so we started in israel
uh we were lucky enough um to start with
the largest public transit company in
israel agate
which is doing almost 50 of the entire
country public transit wow uh i think i
always say to other founders where you
know they think about should we build a
company for enterprise customers the
book should go after the long tail
of like the small medium size
business
and i think the enterprise customer they
bring so much value to the development
of the product because they have the
highest and ice requirement
where smaller companies can say yeah i
mean that you know they they can go with
that without although right yeah i think
we started from the largest one in
israel uh then very quickly we grew to
about like 90 of the market in israel i
think like
within less than two years
before we even had like uh a good enough
product i would say uh at that point and
and why and why is that is that because
you know now there's now they're they're
seeing the value proposition through egg
is it because
you know what how do you attribute you
know the fact that once you go with the
head all of a sudden you have the rest
are following suit so i wasn't sure it
was because we were with the largest one
and they said okay optimus is probably
the best because they went with the
largest one i think what was really
helpful is that we can show the roi
uh
very accurately and uh in quite fast so
we will go to a public transit company
we'll tell them okay you spend 100
million dollars a year
running your transit system
maybe 75 million is driver wages and 30
and 25 is a vehicle or or something like
that where fuel maintenance and so on we
put all the data into optimus and that
takes some time because we need to make
sure the data is accurate and so on also
the constraints union agreements we do
all of that we do all this work
and then we let the system run and
output different scenarios and we'll
tell hey instead of 100 million you can
run it in 90 million
that's only 10 million dollars of
savings
and think about a public transit company
that is works on a margin of like five
percent six percent yes so
that's a big deal ten percent more five
percent more it's big big deal i think
that was like the main factor why we got
uh quite quite fast involved you see
like this away you can't really ignore
it
it doesn't really matter what tool you
use today you really want to move to
that because
you get like an immediate ally
were there cultural adaptations that you
needed to do as you're branching
globally
and you're working in more than 500
cities so obviously you know you're
dealing with different cultures and
before you mention how how minded you
are to equity and diversity and and
figuring out okay which populations here
needed more versus it's it's more of a
luxury basis how how do you go about and
do that at scale yeah with so many
different locations
so we started in israel then we moved to
the u.s
first deal in the us by the way was done
all through linkedin
messaging actually and quite fast but it
wasn't uh
let's say representative oh foul really
made uh was lucky i guess to get the
first customer in the us then we moved
to europe starts from the uk then
germany i think one we was once
what we learned quite uh early on is
that public transit is quite similar all
over the world and all over the world i
mean africa
hong kong
singapore brazil u.s canada you know
germany sweden like many very different
places but public transit in the end is
about vehicles drivers moving people
around so in that is very similar but
what is very different
is that each company and each public
transit agency has very different
rules that they go by it could be
regulation and state rules and
governments so so on but could be also
union agreements
and preferences of different uh trinity
companies so
what we did quite early on is that once
we understood that is we build it into
the product so you can customize it
fully like you can say
this driver needs a break every four
hours
and you cannot drive more than 10 hours
and uh you know you should use a double
decker here and single decker there like
you can customize all that to anything
you want so the product is the same
product
single you know multi-tenant system
and you can customize it on the fly for
each customer now what we did
learn uh after a few years
is that you need to have
in terms of the go to market sales
marketing and also customer success you
need to have people on the ground
different languages first
the market are very close and everyone
knows each other like it's really hard
to go from israel on sale to
you know a company in a random place in
the world
so we have an office offices in many
different places like we have in europe
in europe in many different places in
europe we have in the us we have in
brazil
with that i can only imagine in the
operation that that one the one has to
run at this at the stage and
going back and
before
princeton and
microsoft is there any part of you that
that feels that you're gonna go into
this world that you're gonna go into
public transportation or that you're
gonna work in in in this type of role
um i didn't think that this uh will
happen uh back then
even after the years that we worked on
optibus we had a product uh it was
working we have customers and during all
that while i'm working full-time job at
microsoft
even then i wasn't
like 100 sure that's what i'm going to
do
uh
i think the move of moving from
microsoft to to
pounding optimus today it looks trivial
but
back then it wasn't trivial at all
uh it wasn't clear to me that the
problem that we see in israel
exists in other places in the world
uh also think about like i was in a
really good place
i really liked working at microsoft and
uh you know successful and get promoted
like you don't want to leave a place
like that and on the other end you're
not sure like startup is always about
risks you're not really sure you need to
at some point really we really needed to
make this jump uh we did a lot of
research before and so on looking at
other companies and we understood that
there is a big pain point
but we didn't really know for sure now
we know that it exists anywhere anywhere
you go
it's uh always amazed me to see like we
went to london
and we saw all of the public transit in
london
all of the routes are planned using like
this one huge excel file
and you're saying hey it's like one of
the best
public transit networks in the world
like you know maybe 10 million people
are you know living in that area and so
on so yeah
the reason was that one of the aha
moments that you thought okay like we
get this like we get what's happening
here
we know what we need to be doing it's go
time that was definitely one of the uh
moment uh the industry is huge the
public trends is about one half trillion
dollar industry
um
we are not only doing public transit
we're doing a lot of private
transportation we're doing uh
you know we're doing all the
transportation for companies like
facebook apple uh and others we do event
transportation universities uh
airports transportation about public
transit or mass transit general is a
huge industry
and it also affect the lives of billions
of people around the world that really
relied on like essential
industry and uh there is really no tech
it's a very low tech or no tech kind of
industry
no ai no optimization no cloud computing
it's like really
still
stayed there somewhere in the 80s
so a lot of people
amos if i had to ask you
what your co-founders or your employees
or your other colleagues
what are a few words that they would use
to describe almost
well what would they be
um if you ask people in the company you
know people that knows me especially
people at optibus most of them will tell
you that i'm optimistic
uh even though i don't view myself as
such i give myself more as realistic and
i
i think i can tell you why so startup is
like a roller coaster you always ups and
downs and there are many situations
where there are lots of issues
it could be an executive that left the
company to to open his own startup could
be an issue with a large customer could
be a large company trying to close a
deal and you're not sure you know you
get it and so on
um
and so it always looks like things are
going wrong and you know it's always
like roller coaster but
i think what
what i'm doing at this this situation i
try to look at the long term
and if you look long term and not like
what's happening in this week or this
month
and so if you look at the long term the
vision and mission is what counts and
that's always optimistic
i love it
i i really appreciate your work i
appreciate this conversation but i
appreciate your work even more because i
think that
you know it's just
such an amazing example um you know
a company that has such wide arms and
and impacts you know not just people in
different places but the impact is the
way that that authorities make decisions
and very complicated decisions that at
the end you know after a complicated
supply chain impact to really everything
and so i think it's a it's an amazing
journey over seven years and
and it sounds like it's an amazing place
and a very fascinating time
and
and really leveraging interesting
technology to do some really good things
for people so thank you very very much
for the inspiration and best of luck and
stay safe and stay healthy thanks a lot
thanks michael thanks for having me
thank you
you